get to those roads nate's got his eye on  a few problem spots at 6 31. oh it's one  problem spot the rest of the freeway  system sharing pretty good shape but  this is a big deal if you're in the  boulder city or henderson area and you  use the 95 515 or i11 to get into town  you should think about taking another  way because for some reason  i don't know why these things happen but  for some reason there's a repaving  project going on at 6 30 in the morning  northbound on the i-11 at horizon drive  you got one lane to get through so we  have suggested detours you're coming in  from henderson or boulder city get off  the i-11 at wagon wheel or at horizon  you can take boulder highway up to lake  mead that will get you back onto the 95  515 because  you're going to lose about 15 20 maybe  30 minutes of your life here  john heather